- Let's tackle some exercise
with picture graphs,
and once again, I'm using the Khan Academy
exercise to do this.
It says, which towns had fewer sunny days
than Sparkle City in June?
All right, so, if we look at
the picture graph down here,
each picture of a sun
represents six sunny days.
We want to say which towns had fewer ...
what did they say?
Fewer sunny days in Sparkle City in June.
Sparkle City is this one right over here.
Sparkle City had, let's see,
we have one, two, three, four, five
pictures of a sun.
Each of those represents six sunny days.
Five times six ...
Sparkle City had 30 sunny days in June.
Which of these had fewer
than 30 sunny days?
Well, you can just look at
the picture graph itself,
and all of Sunville, Shinny
Town, and Star Village,
they don't have as many of
these pictures of the sun.
They all had fewer sunny days.
We actually don't even have to calculate
how many sunny days
each of these represent.
Although, if you cared, this
would be four times six,
this would be 24.
This would be two times six or 12.
This would be three times
six or 18 sunny days in June.
All three of them, Sunville,
Shinny Town, and Star Village.
Sunville, Shinny Town, and Star Village
all had fewer sunny days
than Sparkle City in June.
Let's keep going.
Let's do a couple more of these.
The graph shows how
many mice a farmer found
in here field each day for five days.
Which day did the farmer
find the same amount of mice
as on Wednesday and Thursday combined?
All right, let's look at this.
Each picture of a mouse
represents two mice.
See, on Wednesday and Thursday combined,
there's two ways to think about his.
On Wednesday and Thursday combined,
I have one picture of a mouse,
and then two more pictures of mice.
That's a total of three pictures of mice.
What other day do I have
three pictures of mice?
Well, Tuesday I have
three pictures of mice.
I could just pick Tuesday.
Another way to think it is
on Wednesday, the actual number
of mice that were observed,
one picture means two mice.
Two mice on Wednesday,
four mice on Thursday,
because I have two pictures
each of them represent two mice.
Two on Wednesday, four on Thursday,
so six total.
You see on Tuesday we have
six mice were observed.
Once again, each of these
pictures represent two.
Two, four, six.
There you go.
All right, let's keep going.
Funland had blank
millimeters less rainfall
than Happyville in August.
This right over here,
this is Funland, this is Happyville,
and each little raindrop picture
represents six millimeters.
Funville has two raindrop pictures,
Happyville has four raindrops pictures.
Funland had two less raindrop pictures.
I had two less of these raindrops.
Two less raindrops would be
two times six, it would be 12.
12 millimeters less
rainfall than Happyville.
Another way you could
have thought about it
Funland had 12 millimeters
of rainfall in August.
Each of these six then 12.
Each of these represent six millimeters.
Happyville had six,
12, 18, 24 millimeters.
12 millimeters verses 24 millimeters.
Well, Funland's going to
have 12 millimeters less.
12 millimeters is 12
less than 24 millimeters.